29来群长89来这款谁要2929扣1
2929谁要谁来扣个1
谁要谁来扣个1
来来来谁要谁来扣个1
我上次不是给你台风来了
台风来之前的艳阳高壮
今天还好37度
我上次不跟你说发错意义相离
把人家的那个发走了
他让我赔钱赔了50块钱
去掉快递费
来元领赔了50块
来这款元领元领
来这款黑色黑色的简单的
赔什么
上次那个回家发快递发那个离
然后他那个离跟我们那个离婚在一起了
没有
然后我
我心里想因为我我装了我我就是说装了十来箱吗
十一箱装了十一箱
完了之后我我我到后面数的
我说我说咋去
我说怎么装来怎么出来两箱
因为我想给我女儿发一箱就可以了嘛
然后我后面数的时候一下出来12箱
然后我当时还说怎么又装多了
我说那就算了
给我女儿发两箱嘛
结果就是给我女儿也发两箱
结果没过几天
人家快递找我说
把人家的发走了
当时那边
对
因为他他他那个单贴到背面的
我们也没看到我们单就贴到这面了
但现在也不知道是哪一箱是有双面的
赔五十卖六十卖六十的卖六十多的
卖六十块钱一箱的赔了他去掉快递费
其实快递费
呢
有的如果发
声通的话要十八 yuan的要十八十六
然后这一块我来量一下
我听一下
香味香味八十倍拉到九十六
因为我保疗鸭一点变量
要可是我从以前哪个去你一场五十五来这个群
这个这个一场五十五来这块谁要谁来喝十九十九口一十九口
19扣1
然后我本来想还他15个厘
他不愿意
他让我赔
赔就赔吧
因为厘我们那边远不认识
一般的话就是说
一般的话都无所谓
一般就是上回法厘
法厘一想
马路里哪个厘
压得法厘了
法厘呢
法厘呢也不知道
反正不在回厘那就是这厘那厘
我本来要在回厘
我几个厘带了几个厘
给我让扯底下来
我等会给你放一扯
来这一款直筒直筒的
包腿的这个裙
黑色黑色毛泥的
黑色毛泥
我们这边双面单
作为异常借退回的
你们是大借
基本上都是赔偿
不是我就奇怪了
双面
但是发不走的
他肯定会核查的
到底发哪个地址
对不对
但他没有打电话
我们也不知道
他没有打电话
来这一款毛五十拒止五十
对吧
一般他都要打电话的
你这个上面怎么贴两张单
对不对
哎
我目前不知道哪个贴两张单了
来这一款来这一款来
给宝贝看一下两边
要么他就没有
要么他那个就是没有贴
没有贴单
来腰尾的话
六十八七十腿尾的话
九十二一百九十二一百来群场的话是五十七
这是扫借的问题了
对啊
来这个谁要九块九块扣零扣零来这个毛尼的秋冬款的这个群啊
九块扣零
九块扣零该你倒霉了
今天赔了
今天赔给人家了
不愿意
他几个要他老投诉
摸摸摸来回来
好想把把子啥子
那他他会了
他他卖给人家的六十块钱一项
他说的还好
还是好说话
爱慕吗
反面反面容易
对爱慕吗
爱慕吗
他摸在外的还老投诉
我老投诉
我给他说
我给他找给他解决
他老投诉
我一天投诉我几位
他会的
我给来这个马甲
哎呦
马的来这个马甲马甲不规则的不规则的这个小马甲来
我来量一下
他原来要六十
我想你快递费得去掉吧
对不对
你又没法快递来
兄妹的话
102110长度的话
五十九长度
五十九来九块九块扣一加币
你来啦
欢迎你要这个权啊
是吗
亲爱的
你要这个权是不是啊
大劫不容易反灭
他们就少了
对
如果扫到那一面
他就发走了
我扫了这一面的话就发到我们了
对吧
有可能是这样的
来花还笑
谢谢你下午好
来九块九块啊
你要那个马甲是吧
要这个马甲是不是啊
是吗
亲爱的嘉宾
我几个回家
你不知道我跑到多少地方
欢迎欢迎跑到城堂
把车洗洗又加了一袋那个玻璃水
我把我妹妹她的小孩的被子啥的给他送过去
又又又
其实死了
你不是我回来我一吹人啊
是这个吗
嘉宾是不是这个亲爱的回回
我是不是这个马甲
是要这个马甲不
你冒汗
他要的是黑色的那个马甲吧
我不知道他要的哪个哪个马甲
这个黑色的不规则啊
九块我蒙了
sorry sorry
亲爱的不好意思
不好意思
,忘了忘了忘了
光聊天了
光聊天了聊得好黑呀
来385谢谢谢谢嘉宾
谢谢你那个啥啊
再再再拼一下
因为咱们19块9才发货呢
亲爱的啊
19块9才发货呢啊
再拿一个
可以
来这一款
这个靴子
这个不搭
最后一个
以及还属于我的
也是因为这个黄色的衬衫
我觉得这个衬衫不搭
就非常的显得不合适
啊
好
来这一款地球音乐家的这个蓝色的衬衫
面料巨脂 面料巨脂啊 地球音乐家
来 这款蓝的 咱们来量一下
胸围 胸围
胸围100 102
来 长度66 长度66
来 这款谁要谁来抠
来 29 29 抠个8
29 29 抠8
地球音乐家 地球音乐家
来 谁要谁来抠 谁要谁来抠
我这个是GIL的
军马的F的GIL的
军马F的
面料巨脂的
面料巨脂的 看这个
袖子有点泡泡袖
袖子有点泡泡袖啊
袖口有扣有扣牙 领口有扣有扣牙
来看看这个是
GIL的
GIL的啊 看领口里后面也是有两个小金扣的
来来来 军马军马巨脂的
来
胸围胸围126 130
126 130
长度66
来 一长66
来这款谁要谁来抠 29 29 抠个6
29 29 谁要谁来抠个6
来 喜欢的姐姐就抠啊
来吧
我到这里9点多
到这
抠甲到这 9点多
老三说这
一开车他肯定溜汇汇出来呀
来这个藏青色的
来后面打结的 后面打结的 领口后面有一个缝隙口 袖口有扣有扣牙 面料巨脂面料巨脂的
面料巨脂的
来来来
不知道 他准备反仰来呀
胸围100 102 买种鱼的
长度的话61
长度61
来花群看看好的
来这款谁要
这个19
来这款谁要谁来抠29 29 抠个9
是这个吗
小花群小花群
来这个是新款
新款啊腰后面带半腰松紧的
有裤子有拉链他只有一个样衣标
只有一个这个牌没有牌子了
给你看个近距离给你看一下他这个面料
看看
沙沙的
沙沙的非常好看
来我来量一下
腰围68
可以拉到78
横尾的话是140
裙长的话是79
39个小妹妹
要的话扣个3
要的话扣个3非常清爽好看
非常清爽好看的一个花群看看
来39 39扣3
穿到身上凉快得很
四处进风
你看这里
敞开的
里边的水洗标证明他啥也没洗
啥也没写啥也没写
来
面料垂不
面料也属于垂的
也属于垂的
他就是有点说实话比学访的要好知道吧
比学访的要好
近距离给你看一下就知道了
来一条吧好看夏天穿
又干净又清爽
哎哟
来不来来不来我就等你了
好看的
这个裙子我跟你说
好
这个裙子我跟你说要不然的话早都没有了
因为这个裙子啊
后面走底下翻出来的
不然的话早卖完了
第一天挂这里可点击率老高了
啊这个牌子的是不是
OK谢谢太给力了
啥都知道
先我啥都知道
来这个牌
三个L的面料锯纸
三个L的一个白色
面料锯纸
来这个圆领前面有个领结
有扣有扣呀领口有扣有扣呀
袖口有扣有扣呀
面料锯纸的三个L的白色啊白色
来
胸围胸围胸围
胸围是
108 110
长度的话是61
来这款谁要29 29扣3
29谁要谁来扣个3
来喜欢的姐妹直接就扣29扣3
29扣个3
好的
还是没有
还是没有啊
看他今天别气别气
等他今天的话看你收到货有没有
等他来了我问他一下
看他有印象吗
来386
那我跟你说如果没有的话这边
也没有跑单那我跟你说那就
发给别人了
只能等别人收到货
看那个啥
看在哪
你等今天看他发货有没有给你发
因为昨天你跟我说的备注号是错的对吧你昨天是找这个衣服吧
是找那个绿的吧
来386 386
3 2 1好截图
谢谢
不是另一件
来这一款来给我们看一下
这个牌子的
来棉
人棉9
聚酯5%
L码
棉人棉加聚酯聚酯只有5%
我剩下都是棉的
来这个
T
白色长袖的这个T
前面是刺绣的啊
前面字母是刺绣后背是光满
前面刺绣字母后背的话是光满